[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Launching an app
may not always go as planned.
That's why we created
Start on Android by Google.
Start on Android offers
select developers
in pre-launch mode access to
Google's premier resources
so you can launch
your app like a pro.
With Start on Android,
you'll have access
to Google Play's large
pool of beta testers who
will provide you with
private and honest feedback
across a wide audience.
You'll have design
reviews, technical support,
and business consultations
from experts across Google.
Utilize Google Play's
advanced developer tools
to iterate on this feedback to
build the best possible version
of your app.
So if you're launching
an app and are
looking for guidance
and support,
apply today at Start on Android.